movement and
this is number 4 in the series so rich
what's going on oh my I don't know been
so busy for the last for four or five
weeks they haven't done too much out
with the inspired movement but what are
you busy with just busy with shooting
just busy with work you know I've had a
bunch of different projects that was
away for a while as well on a job so
then kind of in and out of town and
upcoming I've got in-laws coming so it's
gonna be busy time coming up to but
that's no excuse gotta wake up earlier
haha that's right man inspired here we
go oh no wait we met on the weekend and
I gave you a challenge you did you did
give me challenge how did we do on the
challenge now I'm not so good the the
accepted kind of left so i'm waiting for
that moment of excitement unless he told
me i have to create that excitement did
you do it at all no i didn't oh man rich
was going on rich and i had a deep
conversation in the deep and he was he
was getting excited about something i
said rich you gotta go home and film you
gotta kill me right now you gotta film
it while you're inspired and excited and
he didn't do it right but but it by the
time i get there it's like a hour later
it's not as exciting or had an hour to
think about it and worry about it the
head is shaking man and had a shake i
get the head shake the head of shaking
its pretty bad and it's very bad very
bad okay i also need a high res picture
of you for these things doctor about
this right we did we did yeah rich
picture hi res picture for your very
picky you wanted hi res you wanted
against a black background no no it
doesn't have to be black background what
does it have to be whatever just just
for the YouTube thumbnails I need
something high res if it's okay for some
nail you need a high-res image yeah why
that's how we do man
again thumbnail isn't like that big oh
but but it if it's if the videos on top
of the page i got my site I embed video
right oh the thumbnail becomes the whole
banner okay that's pretty close though
what do you have planned there oh well
just with these videos I'm gonna have
you I'm gonna have your picture as a
thumbnail cool people can follow along
and no there there watching rich I just
watched your Eminem success video that
was pretty cool it's pretty wild man
that's a good video yeah it's very good
video well what's the process for you
with that okay so for those you watching
i made a video of mmm his story and how
crazy it was him growing up and all the
all the little man in his life uh trying
to be the first you know white rapper
and being beat up and anyway uh and i
did that story on top of his lose
yourself video and I thought yeah on my
channel and this is part of belief and
it's part of inspired to what I do is
share stories of famous entrepreneurs
and how they became successful because
that helps inspire me and keeps me
excited and think wow he could do it I
can do it and showing especially the
early stage stuff the times where they
were and you know they had all these
problems and you know I don't care how
Eminem makes a million dollars now all
right like how to be start for was his
first first entry how did he get known
and sharing those stories and artists
and musicians have their entrepreneurs
to wear like my name is about Rory's not
just a singer but there's a lot to be
learned from his success story and so I
thought it'd be really cool to tell his
story while showing his video so the
words come up explaining his story while
while his music videos happening in the
background so i just did as a test
whatever like I throw a lot of throw a
lot of stuff out there a lot of
different tests whatever I feel inspired
by and we'll see we'll see how it goes
if people like it it's doing pretty well
so far but we'll see it's blocked in a
lot of countries because of the music
and when I'm come
any whatever is blocking the soundtrack
but anyway I'm glad you liked it yeah
it's really cool okay so rich how do we
stay focused on our goals here what's
happening ah how do we stay focus good
question em and how do we stay focused I
have not seen a rich video for a while I
know but no I have my twitter feed
facebook everything's open waiting for
rich the man to pop a new video I know I
know it's been it's been a challenge
waking up because usually I wake up
early to get stuff done because the only
way I can work from homes by you know
having three or four hours in the
morning for going wakes up but in the
last while I haven't been waking up on
time and I've been busy working so it's
been kind of like I've got all these
videos ready to be put down just uh just
keep the focus on it it's it so what do
you suggest Evan can you take a day and
make it your create this stuff day and
schedule everything out the quotes the
pictures the videos all together and
then you schedule up for the week you
mean a day in a week yeah like friday is
scheduled things out day yeah it can do
that but my my business not structured
yet like yours what's that famous line
of yours that I love so much than Billy
to Wert I don't I don't know how much
you love it because you always forget it
man every time it's a mental block
because I don't have it yet no way what
is it called again no crisis business no
crisis business no Christ business i
love it i gotta make a t-shirt no crisis
business so like I can book that day and
I've done that I've kind of modeled your
days for doing activities but stuff
sometimes can happen in the last minute
well I'll get a booking or something
will happen right away that I gotta
attend to so and that could throw off
that you know this was my production day
could throw that off completely and
that's happened a few times so can you
can you even do enough for two weeks and
one day yeah well that's what I've done
I've done in the past
I'll do a month in one day oh great yeah
I've done that and then I just ride the
wave so you haven't found one day and
I'm in the last month to do stuff
impossible to believe but true true been
sidetracked inside track been a little
distracted well he said what do you
suggest for focus you have a pill for
that I think I gotta come over there and
like chain you to the wall or something
come I told you got a big 12 foot
trampoline and jump a little bit get the
blood flowing it's just important to you
yeah yeah it is so why is it why is
gonna happen why can't we find one day
in a month to make this happen yeah well
I've kept up with the the inspire the
photos and quotes I've spent a couple
days in that month building those
setting those up is it to it it's so
weak what a two-weekend but for the
videos it takes me a lot longer to
create the videos right like I could
spend a day to create a month's worth of
images or a couple days but for videos
you know it could take a while you can
take one you know sometimes the video
could take a week sometimes the video
could take a couple hours so from all
the editing yeah and I gotta well
between the editing in the locating and
titling and you know my my my computer
is dying is falling apart so it takes it
a lot longer does to render stuff up so
gotta basically work out a and decide
what kind of videos i can create that
would be more manageable in terms of
creating one a week like the ones like
where you just record yourself that
would be so much simpler than if i was
doing that then to create edited videos
but i'll help or one of those coming
it's a good question of it but they're
coming soon to a computer screen in you
you can mix it up though right like yeah
and even if all you're doing is the the
videos
when you did with me yeah you broke it
into a couple seconds that I put on my
channel I think you broke it into a
couple the women and then whole thing
right like you can that one video you
can get enough out of flash yeah yeah
and I've got a few of those ready to
roll just a matter of putting it out
there again yeah you got my temperature
rising here man I'm sweating you can't
see it but I'm sweating here I put me on
the spot there that's right well why you
have to be ready to roll / are they
there on the editing on natick room
floor okay but they're coming out what
day is it today there's the thirsty so
Wednesday you'll have one for sure I
like it I like it I like like yeah I'm
gonna honestly just gotta find the day
what you can do it if it's once a month
like offer for twice a month to have the
days yeah and then if one of them gets
cut out and you still have the other
month yeah I mean ultimately it's it's
probably just a BS excuse because it's
possible to figure out the time even if
you know you gotta say a blade or wake
up early you can figure it out just so
huh if I dig deeper there's probably
other ways to get it done or the reason
is going work gotta be important right
things are important to good fun yeah oh
I don't want it and you know like I
can't think you want it you gotta want
it for you yeah I mean these video makes
you want to be videos right filming
videos and inspiring content control
yourself this is a start you're not
giving yourself a start this is the
start I mean that video you made on my
channel has I'm gonna use it to have I
don't think it went up something Oh 24
info well I think it's in the thirties
nap thirties no nice I mean that's just
a start
if you were if you were creating that
kind of stuff on your own channel then
people will be coming back and like
consume the next one in the next one the
next one but it's like you build a
little momentum and then stop and then
everything guy so you getting you ever
build it up and then right like you
gotta you gotta be consistent with it
yeah but i'm just i'm waiting for the
next video where's my next rich video
and like I forget about it mm-hmm like
I'm waiting here's Wednesday I don't see
anything in the next wednesday i forgot
about it you're out of my mind now if it
wasn't like forcing myself to figure out
of track what you were doing then I've
been moving on the other stuff so what
do you got for consistency you gotta
create a schedule + schedule right like
and it doesn't have to be as structured
as me but Wednesday's I make my videos
and I'll often do more than I need to
for that week because you know like
Christine on my video editor she's away
she went on vacation so I had to get
stuff done in advance so if I go on
vacation right it's all kind of planned
around that so I have this huge buffer
of stuff that's already been done
because I did more than I need to one
that day so if you know it takes you one
day a month to do all this stuff then
plan for two days a month the three
dozen muffins if one of the days blows
up on you for you know whatever reason
you know you're working a change to
become a lil crazy business no crisis
business gonna get a tattoo but if one
of the days blows up and yours at the
end of the world you stop stuff coming
up yeah that's true did I get more like
you gotta want to do it like are you
going into it saying oh man I gotta edit
another stupid video well yes and no
something sometimes they are they are a
bit of a job they do take a while to do
some of them so it takes kind of the
right vibes the right atmosphere you
know so it's like if the head space
isn't and that vibe each other you know
how to put
in that head space or you wait for the
next next train to roll around so when
you do stuff that's like you do your
writing do you do it on an inspired
schedule or do you just do it when you
know you need to do it um oh well if I'm
feeling oh my room was going on hold on
i'm gonna cause my Roomba okay i'm gonna
cause a lot of background noise for us
um if I feel inspired to do something
that trumps everything right if I'm
having a great call with somebody or I
get an idea that I want to work on that
trumps everything i'll i'll push I'll
push my video day because I'm in the
flow working on something but you're not
in the flow at least you know I'm not in
the flow all day long right like really
really in the flow where you can work
the five in the morning and not feel it
and you just want to like busting
through because you're so in the zone on
it right if I ever get into that zone
then then then you got to see there as
long as you can otherwise i create days
to do things obviously a writing day
tuesday is my writing day and i try to
get myself set up for writing so i'll
remember why I'm doing this right like
what what's my purpose with wanting to
write this book that I'm working on or
uh you know I have to write another
newsletter this week so it's like oh
I've gotta write a newsletter you right
it's more like I love the newsletter i
love the audience that i have and i love
interact with people and that's one of
the many ways i do it and if i get to
that point where I hate doing it then I
gotta stop right like if you are just
hating doing this work then you can't
keep doing it you got to find something
else so you know you don't necessarily
have to love every single moment of it
but if you're dreading it and putting it
off then maybe it's not the right thing
you to be doing you know maybe maybe the
editing isn't your thing if you need a
partner to do the editing and you'll
kill me I don't know like I'm
brainstorming there's a lock like you
before all this up but you haven't
released it you had the time to go
record it you found time somehow to
connect with people and set up meetings
and go visit them and take the day and
record it but you're not finding the
time to edit it and put it live so this
you have a block there maybe maybe you
shouldn't be doing the video at a day I
don't know you might say haven't that's
stupid i love the video and that's my
thing that's what i'm going to do Wi-Fi
style but like I'm just throwing ideas
out there why why you're not hitting the
bull's that you set for yourself mm-hmm
you love the editing sometimes sometimes
but with sometimes what's its a flow
thing from you the editing if I'm not in
the right headspace the editing just
doesn't work for me so so when you have
your day set for task a and B whatever
how do you get yourself in the zone
again you remember why you're doing it
or is there another process I always
remember why so there's a couple things
that I do uh in the morning to get me
set up and excited regardless of what
might ask is for the day so um I wake up
and I'll put on music I made a playlist
that i love right like when that you
know there are some songs that come on
when they come on me like you know
you're you're feeling the vibe you suck
enix you might be dancing a little bit
you might jump around whatever like it's
not the it's not the slow romantic
celine dion stuff but stuff that gets
you going and excited so I have my
playlist that Eminem song is on my
playlist that's why I made it into that
video because I love Harry that song and
it kind of gets you it breaks you out
because even if you had a great day
yesterday today you wake up and it's
gone like all that flow disappears and
you're starting from scratch and so I
find listening to great songs that I
love and enjoy gets me just active and
excited
not not slow in the morning from there
i'll always remember why so i have a big
one in a slow wide the big why is you
know what am I trying to do and
specifically when we try to do today so
they seriously fears my public facing
day today I do my radio show and I I
just came up with three meetings and
coming to you and then you know more
stuff so just remembering like why I
want to do that cuz i want to help a
billion entrepreneurs and by doing these
calls and this show it's not just
another radio show like it has to be
more important right me talking you it's
not just another conversation it has to
be important it's take enough time in my
day and I want to use it to inspire
entrepreneurs yourself and other people
and then my little wise are more the
feedback that I get so I have the
everyday I wake up when I look at my
comments from my youtube channel so
YouTube and Twitter and Facebook and
everybody saying great video loved it
thank you so much you know change my
life all this great stuff and that keeps
me excited and motivated to continue to
make more and I want that for you like
when you suck any feedback on your
videos that's the ultimate drug that's
like yeah I made something hmmm that's
touching people's lives you know like
you wanted to go and do more so I look
forward to that in the morning to open
my my email and look at their comments
at a time in not the email but the
comments i love the comments um what I
also find helpful is then I try to set
up the day with talking to somebody or
doing an activity that gets me in the
zone for that day so on wednesday is my
video video de the first person i'll
talk to the first thing I'll do is have
a session with my media coach Jennie and
we'll walk through some of my old videos
and chicken wings feedback and tips and
so kind gets me in the zone ready to go
I hang up with her boom I'm off making
videos so she kind of helps get me in
that zone Tuesday and Friday have calls
with my agent Steve and so on tues we
might talk about the book deal that I'm
working on and
I hang up the phone with him and I start
working on my book so it kind of gets me
in that zone um Thursday today is my
public-facing day I had my radio show
this morning and that was the first
thing that I did in terms of my kind of
work stuff outside of the comments and
all that and then go into the radio show
and then meeting meeting meeting meeting
rich yeah it sets me up for the day so I
don't know if there's somebody that you
can connect with or talk to or maybe
there's a video you watch or something
that kind of sets you up for the day I
find though when like you're interacting
with somebody you feed off of their vibe
and you get more energy and hopefully
you hang around people who give you
energy not you know suck it away and the
right person to talk to the give you the
right energy so what who do you talk to
when before you talk to them or when
you're talking they get you making you
want to go make editing awesome you know
like II you end up talking to them and
then you off the guy I'm gonna go edit
kill it editing right like that's person
you want to set a 10am call with and
talk to them and then go start working
but all those things combined so having
a you know music set list that you like
to kind of get you energized remembering
why you're doing this looking at the
small whys of the comments and feedback
you're getting and then set in your day
up to start with something great that's
going to get you in that zone for that
particular day I do that every day and
that helps me kind of get geared up to
then you know have energy for the rest
of the day right because we'd be on this
call right maybe you leave this call you
like oh yeah now I'm energized haven't
got me all excited I'm ready to go but
it's three o'clock you know like these
have gone plus right like you don't want
the energy now I mean it's great but you
want it at seven in the morning and
whatever you're waking up to kind of get
that vibe going so I now happens a lot
of entrepreneurs but creating an
environment that supports you and give
you energy especially early in the
morning for your routine set you up to
have a successful complete days only
like an afternoon
okay what's logic Jack's there you've
inspired me i'm gonna create a couple
playlists it's gotta work is that that's
probably something that's totally
missing is having something that would
be inspiring you know early in the
morning or late at night or whatever
whether it's music or a couple
inspirational videos or in or something
with cool editing to get me all riled up
about that so that's probably a really
great idea yeah music is great you know
meditation is your thing if watching an
arrow Thomas video is your thing or
whatever it is something to get you
pumped in the morning and ready to go
can you do that every morning it's like
my eating breakfast yeah mental
breakfast yeah yeah pretty much yeah I
pit and it it sets me up for a good day
right like my and and I also had the guy
just fight with my mind radio show to
get Thursday they wanted to give me a
different day like no no I want thursday
i want to have thursday because i didn't
even tell them why because they thought
I think I'm nuts like there's this my
public facing day and this is going to
be the start to my day I need a good
solid day to launch with give me my
radio show for thursday you know I
didn't say that but uh that's why I
wanted it on thursday and i fought the
habit and that gives me a the energy to
have a great thursday and have that yeah
every two weeks to the radio show but um
yeah it is like eating breakfast the
music is simple right music I have a big
glass of water that yeah you know I sold
a drink bill today um and how much I can
I take glass of water and what is that
for oh you got to be hydrated man you
want energy you got it you got to be
hydrated because this used to say go for
it on the side but as lemon water you
should go through one or two of these a
day if you're tired during the day and
it's not because you didn't have enough
sleep is because you're dehydrated oh
you get energy from water there you go
we're covering lots of different topics
but rich man we got to get some videos
up I know I know we will
are you the person edit the videos and I
the person to edit the videos it's a
question i'm gonna i'm going to take
into the deep with me okay now I'll come
back with an answer by our next session
yeah my god but I added I've edited most
of my stuff throughout my uh you know as
for as long as I can remember do I love
it sometimes do I want to continue to do
it all the time not so sure but I'm
gonna I'm gonna meditate on that for a
little while can come up with some
solution either to join up with someone
or Portuguese just do it yeah I mean
once you have once you know you want
something to happen it's a lot easier to
find a solution and I just think about
how easy it was for you to go line up
all these people to talk to and how
excited you were about doing it and the
gear and everything you've said all this
stuff up and then nothing releases yeah
you know you did you found the time to
do that and you've got all excited about
that but not about actually releasing it
to the world yeah editing so that made
that might be a sign that the editing
the weak link there huh yeah and
exciting i've got a few interesting
people lining up for interviews as well
so sports celebrity so it sits in them
it's in the process right now that's
what you like to talk about and what
you're excited by right where there's
going to be other people who say man
i've got this editing style that i want
to play with you don't even know what's
coming down the pipe of this editing
random nazi want to partner with
different videos where you're out there
is there other people who love to edit
who will who will be way too afraid to
go and approach people and talk to
people regular I don't wanna I don't
want to interview people I don't want to
leave my house I want to want to cut
film massive where would you suggest to
go for that because I don't you have a
lot of different work that you farm out
what would he suggest
is good avenues to start looking your
two paths are 12 either way three
options 12 to partner with somebody so
they become not a partner in your big
business but like you now are creating
this inspire channel together and you
get credit and your phone you've gotta
love and they get credit they're
promoting whatever right so you guys are
the tag team your your your John and
Paul you know you're out there thing um
so that's one the second is you hire
somebody and you could that you know
class one right you got to hire somebody
you could get somebody on odesk works
remotely and do this stuff for you but
there's budget you know issues that you
have to figure out and the third one is
to have an intern come and work with you
and that would be more you know you have
the personality where you like coaching
somebody and working with somebody in
imparting your knowledge and maybe doing
the higher level stuff and having them
focus on more than grunt class if they
can learn um but they're gonna make
mistakes and it's not going to be quite
right and you have to step in and fix it
and you gotta like the coaching and
leadership mentoring role if you don't
then it's not going to work um so I
guess it depends which one you want all
three of work I've used all three in my
past as well I haven't you prefer or has
worked best for you all of them will
work i guess it just depends on what the
role there you know um you know my
business now i don't have partners don't
have business partners but i've
partnered up with a lot of people to
make amazing things like like the first
believed by video with mature is em
right work together on it we did most of
the work i just gave him a little bit of
direction he wasn't it something awesome
and i love partnering up with people who
are really skilled at something and
there's a way to collaborate somehow
maybe that's how you start you don't say
you I have this huge idea how we're
going to work together for the rest of
our lives you start on one collaboration
and you see how it goes uh the videos i
do now i have like i've paid Christina
to come and help and she does all the
editing and all that she loved it did
that Eminem video yeah she did the M&M
video so I I wrote the copy and I got
the song like this is the song i wanted
and my actual vision at the start was
just to have pictures of mm and and
effects on society and well I'm her own
rip and put the video in and she made it
way better than I what I came up with
yeah cool I loved it yeah I love that
I'm really proud that we made that and
so it's also giving people the freedom
who work for you to explore their own
creativity and then they find a path
that you know that is different than
what you thought but ends up being a
much greater result um and I've had
interns to you know in terms of skill
level is a lot lower but I enjoy the
coaching part of it and seeing somebody
develop and learning something new when
they get all wide-eyed wow you can do
that that's amazing and so it also helps
remind me of how amazing it actually is
right like I do a day in day out it's
nothing now but to see somebody come in
you know then that fuels your excitement
and and having having interns can often
give you energy and feel make you feel
motivated together you know young person
coming in ready to learn and they love
everything but it's a matter of finding
my people and and you could text like
you don't have to have one strategy and
that's it you could try to find somebody
to work with on a project one video and
you go produce it you could try to find
somebody to work for you on one project
and see if it works well and you could
try to find an intern to work for one
semester and see if that works and see
see what you love see what works best
you know it's one of those things that's
hard to plan like you can have the
greatest plan in the world on paper but
then you when you start to execute it
you hate it you're not going to throw
everything into it it's not going to be
a great person all right you have to get
great results doing things that you hate
yeah so it's really just going out and
trying and testing and seeing what you
where you find your flow and what vibe
you feeling if you like it you like it
you continue if you don't you stop them
something else that's why I brought up a
lot of anything because like you're not
doing it you're not in the zone you're
not getting the flow out and I want to
see videos Wednesday's damn right so I
mean the solution for this week maybe
hey I'm going to brute force it I'm rich
I'm gonna get to work and you know I'm
gonna find my inner whatever and and get
it done but I mean you can only do that
for so long before you get tired of it
and move on so if you're not feeling the
love then your best bet is going to be
getting some help partner fire or in
turn to will help you I built this thing
up yeah I'll explore that all right some
thoughts to think about for the month
and I'm looking forward to seeing that
video Wednesday who's it gonna be this
Wednesday you're not sure we'll see all
right a few of them ready so we'll see
what feels right okay cool little tiny
surprise looking to clines it'll be
surprised video on Wednesday cool okay
for people watching where can they find
out more info on you rich I on me gotta
love calm or youtube / you gobble up I
got the the domain on YouTube you have a
numbers and letters no nothing yeah
automatically they gave me you got alone
cool good looking at home maybe it's
hien it's a sign man it's a son
something's happening he wants more
videos they want more rich love that's
right okay have a great month and we
will judge all right see i cater yes and
send me that picture hi res hi res
picture yes for thumbnail you got it
do that by so later